Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol guys
we've made it through my Mission
Impossible series leading up to rogue
nation coming out very soon and this
just might be the best one now I went
out and bought this on blu-ray back in
the day and since I'm a huge collector I
also bought the steelbook from Target
that was like an exclusive and I've
never opened it it's still in its
packaging and I don't I'll never open it
probably because I'm a weird collector
guy don't judge me and my three helped
revitalize the franchise again because
two is pretty bad but there was still a
very long break in between three and
Ghost Protocol and some people were
wondering if this movie is even
necessary maybe Tom Cruise is too old to
continue doing this my gosh did everyone
involve with ghost Protocol prove all
the naysayers wrong in this film the
entire IMF has been disavowed the
president has invoked ghost Protocol in
classic spy movie style a terrorist has
gotten his hands on nuclear codes and
Ethan Hunt and his small team are the
only people who can stop him as similar
to my previous mission impossible'
reviews if you have not seen this film
yet this review is gonna contain
spoilers guys so if you haven't seen the
film I suggest checking it out first and
then coming back and watching my review
you've been warned let's talk about this
thing one of the best Pixar directors
there ever was was Brad Bird he made
movies like ratatouille and The
Incredibles the guy really understood
how to make a great animated film this
was his first live-action movie and he
knocked out of the park this is an
extremely crisp almost electric looking
movie there's a sleekness to the entire
film a polished look that most action
films nowadays do not have a
cinematography is gorgeous the
hand-to-hand combat was filmed
beautifully stunning wide shots of
incredible stunt work gorgeous looking
stuff this movie brought back the minor
character of Benjy played by Simon Pegg
and mi3 and fleshed out his role to have
a huge part in this movie he's now in
the field he's an operative
he has his computer he knows what he's
doing and he added so much to this movie
so much humor and he was just great with
crews they had amazing chemistry I'm so
glad they're bringing him back for five
they also added Paula Patton and
for a very good backstory as well as a
badass character and jeremy renner
hawkeye himself in the film he also has
an interesting backstory a character
who's harboring secrets that had direct
connections to Ethan Hunt and right off
the bat from the opening scene of this
movie where they're breaking hunt out of
this strange prison it's very
suspenseful which is a great call back
to the original Mission Impossible movie
and something that I think ii completely
forgot about and even three because
three i wouldn't call a suspenseful
movie it was basically a non-stop action
thrill ride mi4 was a great call back to
that first film there was a lot more
about tension and as i already mentioned
with simon Pegg's character there is a
great sense of humor in Mission
Impossible for something that was
lacking from the other two and my three
had a few chuckling moments mi2 had
virtually nothing but this movie is by
far the funniest in the entire franchise
something else about ghost Protocol that
I love every time I watch it is the fact
that it's the first one in the entire
franchise where their spy gadgets don't
always work it was such a great idea
because up until then the mission was
always impossible because it was really
hard but their tech pretty much always
worked in this film it's not just a
really difficult mission their tech
keeps breaking as well which makes it
even more impossible er that's not a
word from early on in the movie when he
gets his famous this message will
self-destruct in five seconds from this
old telephone it doesn't work he's got
to hit it really hard for the message to
self-destruct the mask maker that's
making their disguises that thing breaks
and they have to go on without masks
when he's using his gloves and the
famous Burj Khalifa scene they start
malfunctioning the laser cutter
malfunctions every bit of their tech
malfunctions and that was such a great
idea because it made you feel like they
were actual people and less like these
amazing invincible superhero spies that
have everything perfect all the time
another thing that Brad burden the
writers did so well in this movie was
maintain a constant sense of urgency
every scene feels important there always
is this sense of we have to get going we
got to go something's bad about to
happen we need to get this going and it
was always this intense level of
adrenaline throughout every scene and
that was something that was really
important but this film understood how
to make it flow better because the
problem I had with three even though I
really enjoy it is that yes it's intense
it's urgent there's always something
happening but there was rarely ever
those character-building moments and it
was sort of way too fast and too much
happening at once that was my only real
issue with three with this film they
maintained that thrill level but they
stretched it out they fleshed out the
characters as best they could so you
could actually care more when this crazy
stuff was happening but by far my
biggest issue with this movie is
definitely the villain this is something
I've talked about in my previous three
reviews the Mission Impossible series
has a hard time with compelling villains
Philip Seymour Hoffman was probably the
best one we've had so far in the first
film spoilers for him I won Jim Phelps
who was eventually revealed as the
villain he's not really the villain
until the end I mean you know he find
okay he's been a villain the whole time
but it wasn't really till last couple
scenes that you realize that Jon Voight
was great in that movie but in this film
I think it might actually be the weakest
villain of the entire franchise because
even at mi-2 at least the villain was
there constantly and they actually cut
back to him a lot he was a bit of a
cartoon character but he was a villain
the one at mi4 might actually be the
worst of the entire franchise is
portrayed by a great actor Miquel
nyqvist sorry if I said that incorrectly
he's fantastic he just didn't really
have anything to do in this movie
originally there was a deleted scene the
very opening scene was going to be him
this big scene that kind of flushed him
out a little bit more but they cut it in
favor of a more intense opening which I
understand but his character is really
just an evil guy who wants to blow stuff
up and he has a strange reason for doing
it it just was not a good villain it was
a very boring character and by far the
worst part of this movie they're real
antagonists I like to think is the
situation the heroes are constantly in a
terrible situation as I said the sense
of urgency something's always going
wrong something's always breaking they
always are just a little bit too late to
whatever they're trying to get to to me
that's really the antagonist of this
movie because the actual antagonist is
so boring let's talk about my favorite
sequence in the entire movie the Dubai
sequence I'm not just talking about the
amazing building scene but the chase
through the sandstorm all of that is
action movie gold it's perfectly
directed stuff I love it my issue with
it despite the fact that it is perfectly
directed in my opinion is its placement
in the film
there's a sense that the film Peaks
early with a Dubai stuff and then what
happens after that where they have to
infiltrate this party and Paula Patton
has to seduce this rich man the film
sort of stalls and then it picks back up
again quickly with this fantastic
hand-to-hand combat scene in this
advanced parking deck and all that
finale stuff is really fun but it just
screeches to a halt with this party
scene I just feel that they could have
switched those two acts in a way have
the rich guy party scene more towards
the middle and then the big action II
stuff towards the end but it's a sort of
strange complaint to have to say that
the film is so freakin great and then
not as great but still really good it's
such a nitpicky little thing but as a
critic I look at things like that but
that Burj Kalifa scene is one of the
best action scenes in movie history Tom
Cruise doing all of his own stunts Tim
actually out there filming it his
no-shit joke is perfect every time I
loved it when I showed that scene to my
sister who has a fear of heights she
could barely watch and that is perfect
because you can really tell when you're
watching that scene that's real you can
see Cruz's legs kind of dangling and you
can just tell this guy's really out
there all of these things that could not
have been accomplished inside a set or
with green-screen were accomplished with
that scene and it's one of the best in
action movie history and this movie
really understood the team dynamic of
what Mission Impossible is it's not just
Ethan Hunt show it is a Tom Cruise movie
but he has a team that supports him that
needs to function properly and in the
final scene in the film that's what he
says he says nothing on our mission
worked everything broke except this team
this team functioned incredibly and that
is what Mission Impossible is it's a
team and so great so great to see ving
rhames in that one final scene as Luther
stickell who's by I keep saying this in
every review he's like my favorite
character and the whole franchise I love
that guy and he was so funny and just
the brief time he had now throughout the
entire movie there was this storyline
that Ethan Hunt and his wife had gotten
a divorce and then you find out that
Jeremy Renner's character was actually
there when she was killed in an Ethan
Hunt killed her murderers and ended up
in prison it gave a really good sense of
tension between those two characters
throughout the film but at the end they
decided to reshoot it to have his wife
still be alive but she's kind of in
hiding because he wants to keep her safe
and the
and Brad Bird said he did this was
because he didn't want the film to have
the alien 3 syndrome or from the
beginning of this film all of a sudden
characters from the last film you cared
about are just dead so I liked the fact
that he respected the previous film and
honored it in that way although it does
feel kind of like a tacked on Edition
that doesn't a hundred percent work
all in all Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol is quite possibly the best film
in the franchise it's only competition
in my mind is the very first one I think
it's a great action film it's funny it's
extremely thrilling and immensely well
shot I'm gonna give Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol and a well guys I have
now officially covered every classic
Mission Impossible film leading up to
rogue nation I'm very excited to see
that film I'm hoping it's just as good
as four if not better I'm looking
forward to reviewing that for you guys
if you want to see all my previous
reviews they are on my channel right now
and linked in this description if you
want to check them out guys thank you so
much as always for watching I really do
appreciate it
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes